the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our coverage of the
2023 spring chess classic
my name is Julian perlaco and I'm joined
by women's Grandmaster Tata of
abrahamian and we should take a look at
the standings for groups A and B
where we are so in group a we have
co-leaders some Savion and we have three
co-leaders some Savion tires sweets and
diaster quesada all of all of whom have
one half points and as we are actually
starting this broadcast we do have a
result in the game of ilionic and Samuel
sevyan we can take a quick look at the
game to see where this game
where this game is and how it ended and
before we dive into that game let's take
a look at the standings of Group B
yeah so once again we have three
co-leaders uh with one and a half points
out of uh two games and those people are
Gregory Cantor Victor michelevsky and
aksha Chandra
um and there are lots of people chasing
them with one point uh in second place
the format of the tournament is g90 for
the first 40 moves and 30 minutes for
the rest of the game with a 30 second
throughout the entire game
and the schedule for uh the games is uh
every every day the games will begin
begin at 1 pm Central Standard Time and
there is one round per day with no rest
days
um we will be covering each day about
three uh two three hours after the start
of each round
so let's take a look
at ABI Mishra who's playing
so we saw this really exciting game
yesterday between Mishra and Christopher
you and hopefully we can get one of them
or two of them here to talk about that
game and the key matchup of our round
was elianism versus some Savion both of
whom um actually some Sabian who was
co-leading the tournament and he made a
very comfortable draw with the black
pieces so let's just take a look at that
game and see how we ended in this
threefold repetition which is how the
game ended
so we started with the Catalan so I'm
sorry I'm playing with the black pieces
might be the seven C5 and so far they're
following a game that's um Savion played
against Jeffrey Zhang in the 2021 U.S
championships so this was a preparation
by elianism clearly
and this is where Sam Actually deviated
and he played P5 in this position
so Knight C3 taking advantage of this
pin so in the Catalan this G2 Bishop is
quite annoying and the main focus for
white is to utilize this bishop and try
to do something in the center and along
this diagonal and try to make it so this
bishop cannot develop so B5 is a useful
mode because the bishop goes to B7
so now we have some trades
and 9c6 so this is a really nice move
and it takes advantage of the fact that
the bishop has moved so of course this
is impossible S6 will hang
so in the game the queen went to D7
and now I can isolate Black's d-pawn
which was the point of the move Knight
C6 with the Knight on D4 the queen did
not stare at the D5 Square so you would
just recapture with the queen and black
would be doing very well but the point
of Knight C6 is positionally white
um would like to isolate the pawn on D5
with a Tempo Queen goes to B7 and now
takes so now black has the option of
taking either way but generally we do
not want to
um
a trade a lot when we're playing good an
isolated pawn and I think the problem
here immediately is that after Castle
it's going to be very difficult to
defend the spawn after Rook D1 and even
like with few pieces on the board black
is still behind in development because
the king is still in the center and the
bishop hasn't developed so after
something like this Knight F3 now Rook
D1 is even stronger because it's going
to be very difficult to defend the pawn
and for this reason after 95 Queen V7 he
took with the pawn
Bishop D7
and the root will go to d8 to defend the
spawn
yeah black is using the extra activity
given uh with the E and C files in this
line which is easier to exploit with
Queens on the board than off the board I
feel I feel like yeah and generally the
way we compensate for an isolated Pawn
is through piece of activity and a lot
of pieces have come off the board so as
a general rule when you have an isolated
Pawn you want to keep miners on and play
with peace activity and if you're
playing against an isolated Pawn you
want to trade the miners and the fact
that the light squared Bishop have come
off is quite an accomplishment for black
we had a similar game yesterday where
we're talking about
exchanging the correct Bishop because
there is a Pawn on the light Square so
it's good for black to exchange a light
squared bishop and this is the correct
Bishop to be left with
so Bishop F6 castle and
The Rook will go to the center and P3 of
course makes sense to develop the bishop
under the right diet on the long
diagonal but it also creates a weakness
on the citery Square which can be
exploited with moves before in Knight C3
and putting a piece on C3 and killing of
this bishop
sort of goes to demand attacking what a
black defense and now the other Rook was
2e8
so more pieces are coming off
so now the roof has done its job and
splitting the C3 square and we will see
that a Piece Will land here eventually
so before and this is the setup that
black wanted and now the D5 Pawn is just
secure because the Knight is just
defending from it doesn't feel weak at
all there's no way to attack it and it's
already like triple defended yeah the
weakness is only really a weakness if
you can exploit it if you cannot get to
it then you have to prove that it's weak
for some reason
so King G2 G6 which control the Knight
so A3 targeting before securing the
square
surrogate
text this Pawn plug puts a rook on the
open file and here we see a repetition
this is where it starts so taking this
is impossible
I take this with a check
and this game ended in a three-fold
repetition
so a really nice result for Sam who drew
very comfortably against one of the
highest rated player in the tournament
with the block pieces and pretty quick
game for him which means he has the rest
of the day to prepare for tomorrow
yeah let's go ahead and take a look at
the parents for Group B
so dabasarin is playing against glove
duden with the white pieces Ox shot is
playing against Kirk gazerian which is
an important game because oxshot is one
of the leaders Felix is playing against
Luca Jason Liane against Balaji dagupati
and finally our our key matchup uh
Cantor against mihilevsky both of these
players are leading the tournament
definitely something we want to take a
look at
defeated
Rook with three versus two Pawn so that
was a very long game we didn't see the
end of it during our broadcast and
mikholevsky actually won on time
yesterday we did again
so let's take a look at where we are
the colors playing Black so Knight F3
Knight F6 C4 G6
and E5 so this is a repetition from
round one when he played against Kirk
this E5 move so y takes again
so it wasn't a surprise weapon he just
believes in this system with black a I
guess yeah so this is something he
probably prepared for this tournament
and
analyzed it thoroughly it feels like so
in the in that game white played D4 and
in this game where I chose D3 so clearly
white was expecting this or at least
took a look at this
so it's interesting that rookie 8 has
played because I would have thought the
point of E5 is if you play Nothing move
the Knight E4 would be possible as a
tactic but I guess Knight F7 or
something I actually Knight F7 looks
like you're giving black some activity
so I'm not sure
right
yeah
even this one's just waiting for black
okay so 94 it makes sense so the idea is
what to
take and maybe bishop
H6 I wonder if I can do this and rookie
8 maybe the idea is
quick H4 H5 it's our queen d2h or maybe
here I can go H4 yeah maybe this is my
misunderstanding of these positions but
it doesn't like seem that bad to me as
black it does look it does feel a little
weak on the cane side but like I like
the bishop on E5 it feels like a nice
piece
uh this H4 proof actually might be
difficult to deal with because I also
maybe want to play Bishop G5 or Knight
D5 by followed by Bishop G5 and then H5
and try to just attack you quickly and
claim that you removed one of your
Defenders from H5
and go for this
okay that makes that makes some sense I
guess uh but I guess rookie it is like a
more aggressive intention
so I think taking with the Knight makes
no sense you're right so the txi4 so
this has been played before and Bishop
D2 and Bishop H6 have both been played
uh Bishop D2 I actually kind of like
this move because I defend this
um because in the other lines when I was
considering let's say Bishop H6 here I
think black might actually consider take
this and take on e4 with a check and I
understand we're not supposed to be
giving up this bishop but we will take a
pawn with a check and then Queen will go
to F6 to cover the dark Square so for
example if H4
this
[Music]
yeah you can have sex even though it
might look scary to give up your dark
Square Bishop chess is a concrete game
and well you need compensation for your
lost material
yeah because tactics always supersed
anything positional because if you make
something more tactically all this none
of this matters because if I'm
checkmating you I don't care that my
constructure is ruined and here if I can
get away this is actually really fun if
I can take on H4 it's like from f8 took
on H4 very unusual and I have
it didn't move correctly I have zero
development here but now your bishops
get kicked around and I think I might
actually be able to get away with this
yeah and having Queen H1 check here is a
pretty useful resource I think like
later I might be able to even generate
some attack against white skin if you're
not careful
I was planning on going this way and
so yeah maybe
maybe we shouldn't be playing so
aggressively so Bishop H6 probably helps
black so maybe H4 is better I can try 95
Bishop G5 or just H4 H5 I don't like
this bishop d2 move because
I shouldn't play H4 because H4 is going
to hang again but okay let's say
something like this and this is a better
version though because the bishop on C3
is a Monster yeah so it's against this
bishop this looks very scary so even if
I castle for example oh my God kind of
looks very funny on H4 so maybe you can
go like now you cannot go back with a
drag queen H4 because now I'm already
checkmating you so funny enough you have
to keep your Rook on the Ford rank to
stop Queen D4 but I don't know how long
the Rook will live on the Ford rank so
this is a very funny position
but none of this happened because black
played rookie 8 and white defended the
Knight
with the move F4 and now the Knight is
secure here
so C6 was played with the ID of D5 so
black is playing against this King in
the center and trying to take advantage
of the fact that the Rook is an E8
so Bishop E2 D5 and white simply ignores
this yeah so instead of D5
um why did Black not choose to play D6
followed by D5 because I would think
that the Knight on E5 is
like kind of a develop piece but I guess
I'm letting White's pawns through I'm
not not totally sure so the way we
handle this kind of Pawn tension is we
take this way and then we go E5 so now
you don't have time for something like
D4 because I take with a Tempo here and
I'm attacking your Bishop so you don't
have time to recapture so now you have
to move your knight somewhere
I don't want to go to H5 because when I
get traveled so you go back and now I
secure my center off and now I'm just up
a clean Pond and your Bishop is but
eventually I'll play a five and I think
this was also already winning for a
while this is also hanging probably the
position will be pretty bad even if you
put a Pawn on E6 or C6
oh maybe so D5 I understand the Knight
is good here but I uh I think that the
claim is that your knight is both good
and possibly loose because at some point
if something like this happens then we
can see Knight D5 and yes you have a
good night but I'm attacking it and
my Rook is quite strong
and we're going after the C4 Pawn but I
like how I'd handle this because it's
simply can't certainly he secured his
Knight so he's claiming that his Knight
is great here and you can't kick it away
next we will secure this pawn and go
after this E4 Pawn or maybe at some
point so I'm pushing I want to go after
the F7 Pawn at some point too it's my
knight on E5 if I can
yeah that's also possible so Bishop E3
will be our next move securing this
Center because D4 is a bit loose here
and we can think about next maybe before
or maybe just play normal and put pieces
in the center also an option
so Knight f57 and immediately we see the
bar goes up and Knight of D7 cannot be a
pleasant move to play when you have this
on the queen side
so he's he wants to get rid of this
Knight here and probably play F6 because
if you've got Knight bd7 I'm not going
to react because I'm quite happy with
you taking it so I will play Bishop V3
and if you take I will take this way
well now I'm also weighing upon but open
this file this just looks again this
looks lost yeah also after so after 95
Fe if you play Knight D7 here
um would you consider a move like C5
because like if we take on e4 then maybe
black will play C5 but like I want to
just yeah Play Bishop C4 and generate
some attack around the king side if I
can yeah I think if the Knight cannot go
to D5 if it goes to five on the Knight
goes to D5 this is not a dynamic one a
lot but not the Knight is on D7 so it
doesn't have access to D5 C5 makes sense
because Bishop C4 and and this kind of
moves makes sense because we're trying
to take advantage of the fact that black
is behind in development because this is
a very temporary Advantage black will
eventually catch up so we have a little
time to try to utilize our advantage of
being ahead in development and having
the better pieces
I think simple 94 should be enough
because I'm headed to D6
but um sv5 I think is also quite
tempting because after C5
I think I will win this pawn and then 96
this looks quite bad
so after night fd7 in the game was
played so
the bar drop so this looks bad so 94 and
F6
and in the game took on D7 which I think
makes a lot of sense but also maybe a
Let's uh black to finish their
development but I have to mention that
black is just upper Central Pawn so
maybe the compensation is possible at
some point this is a skill play C5 here
I wonder if that's strong because if Fe
then I play Bishop C4 check and if King
h8 then Knight D6 or Knight G5 something
to that effect seems like black should
be like Rook E7 I don't even play 907 I
play fe5 and Bishop G5 comes I think I
think black will be punished for his
lack of development yeah because you're
playing with all your pieces and black
is playing with very few pieces actually
because this is not in game this Rook is
the only Defender and
um yeah I mean this just looks winning
for um
Bishop G5 is just going to devastate
block this just looks winning because
Knight F7 is going to be very strong
yeah so I wonder what he what he was
afraid of after C5
so check
[Music]
F takes e and
uh so taking only five so we're down a
piece for two Pawns
so we have good material and so Knight
F7 is the third the problem is black
doesn't have moves like I cannot move
any of my pieces like I need to move
this Knight to develop my queen side but
I don't have any squares
yeah I wonder
that's how to find a move here for black
so do you even want to play Knight F7 or
you just might like this I might want to
just take on f8 and
play Knight F7 after I take on f8 like
sorry I uh if you take on F1 then yeah
probably a plane out of seven
Bishop G5 or something
it's very bad
maybe he didn't see something too
concrete and decided not to go for this
it's possible that he simply thought
that 94 F6 Knight D7 that he's just up a
clean phone and why not just grab a pawn
but what I think is White's compensation
is this D4 Pawn because you have to find
a way to defend this because at some
point I might chase away your knight and
go after this pawn and be and now in
this position you really wish your Pawn
was back on F2 so you could play Bishop
B3 but because of this Rook on this open
file there's not going to be Bishop E3
so white we'll have to figure out a way
to defend this Pawn can you even
consider a move like Rook takes E4 here
um yeah this was played actually
and so let me see if I take this way and
I go first like maybe D5 is just good
enough
and just instead of defending the pawn
just push the pawn
so he played he took so Bishop F3 comes
with a Tempo this needs to be
this is such a fun exchange of the G1
nights of this night because the night
went it feels like one of those retro
puzzles like how did the night end up it
actually captured both of the knights
right yeah yeah that's right
and we exchanged P3 okay
F5 develops
but now I'm having a hard time seeing a
compensation for this Pawn because if
you go here I can so this is not under
attack right one two three one two three
we have everything so rookie one
eventually I'll
maybe we can give one do I want to play
King of fun a bit scared if I can get
fun yeah maybe get out of this paint and
eventually go for D5
or maybe just engage one move the queen
probably just play kingage one myself
but
I don't know I'm always scared of this
diagonal yeah King F1 is maybe a bit too
adventurous because of the position
suddenly opens up why is my king on F1
but uh another positive for white in
this position that D5 is coming and D5
is really secured by all of these pieces
so I think this is already
winning advantage or close to winning
like white seems like white should be
able to
win with this extra Pawn because I don't
see any kind of compensation for this
Pawn at this point
yeah I don't see a lot of compensation
for the pawn either although frankly I'm
surprised that I see the bar it gives
like a very high evaluation but if I
play this with either color I wouldn't
think I wouldn't think that I was just
like lost or winning with with either
side I'd be like yeah I'm probably
better maybe much better but I went in
is uh I guess that's just how modern
chess is yeah maybe winning is um
so too ambitious but uh the most kind of
easy right I'll go kingage fun at some
point probably go H3 to make sure I
don't get mated push this Pawn
and then you just the white just has
everything better that extra Pawn better
pieces
just everything is better so I I think
white should be able to convert this oh
they actually
16 minutes against 11 minutes so they're
quiet down on time because we're on move
18 so there's 22 moves to go but I think
white can make up this moves very easily
so King H1 is an easy move H3 can come
um h0 G3 yeah H3 because I think
eventually these Bishops will be taken
off the board then we'll go through one
I think these are very easy moves like
nothing moves to make up the time
so I think this looks really good for
white
and if he wins this then he will lead
the tournament with two and a half
points
nice
do you want to take a look at some of
the other matchups in uh group a yeah
let's go to group a uh so we have one
result Samuel 7's game that ended and
our other leader in the tournament well
we have two more leaders so yes sir
quesada he's playing against Daniel
Darda we had Danielle in round one he
had a really nice Victory against
Benjamin Park and
let's take a look at what's going on
here
so we have
this is going to be as uh this is this
is some anti-semi slav system I used to
play this as white
um so if black plays instead of A6 E6
the point is to go B3 then uh Knight D7
Bishop B2
of B2 and then after Bishop D6 uh Queen
C2 and then there's this funny point of
view Castle here with a black then a
white can play the move Rook G1 yeah
okay and then G4 G5 comes it's actually
like kind of hard to deal with this
practically
um
I think that uh White has good attacking
chances in this system
um so even semi-slaught players sort of
avoid this and play like a a better
version of an A6 Loft sometimes because
E3 isn't the most ambitious system
so so in that position you just don't
want to castle with black you just want
to make another yeah you can play like
Queen E7 and also like castles as in
like winning or anything but
uh yeah this moves are always so
difficult to do it and usually you would
want to strike back with something like
E5 but yeah the point is yeah like take
uh take and if you take with the pawn
the Knight B5 Rook C1 comes and then you
can play with two Bishops left your
knight C7
I wanted to go 98 but this looks very
sad
oh this hangs yeah
what am I doing okay so A6 is played
avoiding all of that so D4 B5
Bishop G4 which makes sense because the
pawn chain is coming so black wants to
get rid of the bishop before putting the
pawn on E6
this is a very funny Pawn structure it's
like a check response Vector
957 H3
so going after the key Pawn text takes
56 A5 yeah I think this is a very
thematic move from White like black
would really like to play the move A5
himself to have this Pawn not be a
weakness later but you have to time this
correctly because if you play A5 like
earlier than c d c d Knight B5 could be
a problem
um something like this yeah you could
just give away the B5 square and maybe
white is pretty happy about this
but we don't have access to the B4
Square which would be compensation for
giving up the P5 Square yeah and if uh
as the game happens white plays them
with A5 then A6 is just a permanent
weakness in every sort of end game
not this way this way yeah so if we
exchange all the pieces send me some
kind of a bishop versus
Knight or something this will just be
very annoying
so in the game we took on C4 which is a
very interesting decision to me because
why we can despawn structure like this
what happens if I just take there must
be something concrete right so castle
and E5 is coming of course E5 is coming
yeah I mean to my eye I just I just like
White's position here just seems a bit
more pleasant because what you have to
Bishop you're attacking this and
just a better Pawn structure but also
Bishop before is coming so this was a
very concrete way of dealing with this
position
[Music]
so if Castle
um oh Castle was actually played against
grantillias versus McShane and white
played Bishop A3
exchanging these Bishops and again we
have this structure and in that game
also they took so this seems to be
very thematic move on C5 and we see this
kind of thing from Queen's campus
decline where black eventually takes on
C4 and goes C5 and tries to
resolve matters in the center and here
actually the bishop on H5 is quite
annoying for white because this Knight
is tied down
but in the game after detects before the
Knight went to D2 so white wants to take
with the Knight the Knight will be
sitting very pretty and C4 yeah this is
a cool idea
um in a lot of these slot positions to
go Knight D2 and I take C4 because it's
a lot more effective when the Knight
takes on C4 than a bishop because it
attacks the D6 Square so if we go like
Knight C4 and the bishop is Bishop A3
black would be in a lot of trouble
so black Castle but okay so we also
exchanged the Bishops so this must be
some kind of an achievement for Block
because
um at least there's no Bishop that's
aiming at A6
so white black castles would take by the
temple Bishop B4
that goes to A4 so the Knight is headed
to B6 at some point
so it looks like white has a pretty nice
grip on this position
and E4 wait this Pawn
what's this part hanging here
can we take
if we take take
I was thinking maybe we can play Bishop
A3 and if you go rookie eight I have
Knight
D6
is coming oh this is very nice because
if Rook well I don't want to go to E7
how much is a rook Circle get Faith
and you want to do this you want to take
and you want to take
and yeah there's actually very little
compensation because this Pawn will fold
the next move after Knight C5 so black
will just be up
healthy exchange and probably picking up
another pond because this Pawn is also
very weak so that did not work out
tactically so the Rook went on p8 and
after E4
Rook B5 so black is really going after
this Pawn so black wants to at least
grab a pawn for uh if they're going to
be in a
strategically worse position
so Bishop F4 and takes so I think black
has to go for this because you know you
have to kind of justify your
your weaknesses the bishop lens on D6
Knight on C5
and apparently this was not the best
move in the position because what
happened because Bishop C3 and then this
is loose so
um white needs to be a bit more patient
here and maybe not allow Bishop C3 maybe
we need to secure this one first or move
this Rook I don't want to move this Rook
because this Rook is I ain't gone A6
they can just go Rook fd1 rook fd1 and
then we defend this D4 Pawn so if the
bishop so next move when we go Knight C5
too many arrows
this A6 Pawn will be hanging so this
will be quite comfortable
but instead in the game the Knight
immediately went to C5 on Bishop C3 so
now this is hanging on Rook 81. so this
is not what white would want white wants
this Rook to be on this file to take
this Pawn but we cannot give up we
cannot do this this is not an exchange
we want and after everything is traded
off then symmetrical Pawn structure bug
is quite happy here yeah maybe even
black has the better minor piece now
because after E5 the bishop on D4 is I
mean sorry I meant like later when black
plays the pawn to E5 then the D4 Bishop
secure in is F2 yeah this was a very
strong bishop and at some point the rule
can come here so this is not what white
wanted to uh it's a rook fd1 would have
been a very nice patient move
prophylactic moves against Bishop C3
so Knight one two C5 Bishop C3 The Rook
81 so now black is exchanging pieces
because black black space and then we
don't have space we want to exchange
so takes coin takes Bishop B5
threatening Bishop F6 oh it doesn't care
so let's see why not so why not we
should have six oh Bishop five six was
played
Queen G4
oh this is I'm always so afraid when
this happens to my king because and
there are some names of positions where
this is allowed and I know that um it
works out for black but I still get very
nervous when my king is in this
situation and all the pieces are on the
queen side yeah this reminds me of a
Vienna positions with DC and Bishop G5 I
think this happens a lot in those lines
too
as the broken structure
so Queen F3
it takes but at least now the bishop can
come back okay
so we're two moves away from the final
position so Bishop goes back so I think
here I would be feeling better with
black and I think the downside is this
Knight because now this night is just
too far away from where the action is
and knights are very awkward pieces when
they go too far away they don't always
come back they just stay there
we put the Knight on A6 on any
reasonable Square towards our cane then
black would be in some trouble
like if we put the knight from A6 to E3
I would much prefer to play White
yeah
so this is a target but this is
a bigger Target because it's a it's a
piece so white plays E5 if I was quite
middle because we're changing the pawn
structure so the idea is if I go here
this is hanging okay so this is going to
be very concrete it's a queen D5 what's
the idea
I guess you move in Knight c7s I think
right no I can't just take oh yeah
there's no way another there's another
piece that can be forked
yeah don't blunder these sorts of
tactics so instead Queen B6 was played
okay so in the game
what happened Knight one two C5 can I
take
what happens if we take so okay
obviously I cannot take because you take
back with a check I don't think I want
to allow this because yeah this doesn't
look very good for me it's permanent
weakness of the king even if the king
doesn't come under attack now it's just
permanently weak so what should black do
here maybe bishop D6
now I can go Knight C5 so there has to
be
has to be a move here what can we do
Rook B3
the repeat three the queen will go to
where will the queen go to her for here
might actually be getting mated
so where can we go
we need a Tempo move we need a forcing
move oh yeah found it yeah because here
um the kind of life or death situation
because I think if you don't find a way
to win this Pawn bike you're just much
worse because the Knight goes to C5 So
eventually
the process of elimination we will find
Rook F5 as we did
but in the game the Knight went to C5
another point is Bishop C5 is impossible
because this hangs with a check and this
is probably yeah we don't even know
of course easier not to capture when
it's not your piece right so rotate his
plate and Knight D7 so what happens if
we capture here
so now that the Rook is on G problem is
not as afraid of having a Pawn on F6 so
takes takes and
take with the queen and still kind of
afraid like Rook D7 here
wouldn't you rather play White
ah this does look a bit scary
how do we defend here
I think I had to take with the I think
taking with the Rook this is very
awkward right
this is I don't like I want because now
my queen just cannot join the action so
if this feels correct to me Quincy
fabric D7
um
like maybe you could even consider Queen
f8 just to go Rook F5 next but
I'm not happy
oh I think Rook D5 or no
this cannot be good because
five or something
maybe I need I need a queen on the seven
rank so
sorry perhaps
or actually Queen F4
coin F4 makes a lot of sense so you
cannot Escape
also black doesn't really have any moves
in this position no this is I don't I
don't want to put my queen on my face
this is quite sad is that an active way
can I go Queen G5 here Rook F5 DF
can you take
yeah and also Queen b7s come in yeah my
activity did not do me any favorites
okay this is just I think Queen C3 move
but even this is just a lifetime of
suffering yeah well Queen C3 was
impossible but oh yeah yeah it's made
but yeah Rick F6 and
Yeah It's just tough so what to do after
Rook D7
yeah I'm really surprised the engine
gives such a low evaluation but here I
feel like I'm
says something like this is seven no
coincidence
such a difficult move to play now that
my Rook went to G8 wow
again process of elimination so we
eliminated all the other moves
uh so Queen F5 also I didn't think could
work because takes takes takes can I no
but here you'll get
yeah it's yeah we wanna one material
after like Rook A1 or something and or
sure Rook q1 also somewhere right okay
so if you if you take this way it's made
if you take this way I win a rook
and then I pick up the Rook
so what can we do here so after Rook D1
King G8 but uh again white will be
up upon and
also weak King I think there will be
some suffering here when you're up upon
and better well so do you have to Pawn
on the compensation right
okay so Queen F5 is not the move so Rook
f8 I guess
process of elimination the last move
this is I think it's very difficult to
play this but uh again maybe this is a
very concrete like Queen of Queen goes
to a five or G5 and we go after this
Pawn so for example if
something like this I have to make sure
yeah but here again maybe getting mated
this is this position is very scary for
black yeah position is a lot sharper
than it might appear at first glance
like every move you can just lose
immediately mostly with black yeah like
this uh so now actually there's a very
real threat of Queen G3 and Rook d8
so Quinn F5 immediately because if you
go Rook B8 I have Queen G3 and this is a
double attack
it's very nice
so you can take on ba with either piece
obviously
so you want this
oh yeah this is just force made
yeah that's nice
no this position looks very scary
so Rook G8 we wanted to take on F6
instead even Knight D7 so it's 97 just
winning a clean Pawn
Queen d8 Knight F6 okay here but it's
not winning a pawn because
look oh Queen D6 I was thinking Rook F5
this feels like a worse version to me
because the Rook I mean we still have
this D4 Pawn but the position felt a lot
scarier when The Rook was coming to D7
and we had this F6 Pawn surrounding
Black's King now it seems like
yeah we're down a pawn but
at least all our pieces are pretty good
at least we're not getting made yeah
this is how I feel when I played the
French and I'm like okay I'm not getting
mated
this sounds reminding so everything life
is good
but
um
so what did he play he played oh he
played Queen D6 and now Rook F5
and now it's black to move so can I oh
he played 26 to defend C6 okay so in
this position he must think that this
Pawn is his he can take whenever he
wants to oh sorry this one is his it
takes it can't take whatever he wants to
so he's defending the C6 Pawn so I think
he doesn't want to go down the pump
which I understand because
why give up upon so he plays Queen D6
excuse me with the idea of Rook F5
and the queen went to E4 so what happens
if I take
something bad will happen to me again I
think I think you can probably just take
that yeah Queen D5 next so if Rook C1
yeah Queen D5 and we're quite happy here
we're thrilled with this exchange and
actually the blacks please yeah because
now you have this before weakness I have
this big pants but they're very easy to
defend
so what to do here with white yeah a lot
of the danger that came from the I came
from White's position is probably gone
now and black has survived the worst of
the attack is what it seems like at the
moment
so yes it looked up scary there for a
bit yes or it might might have been in
uh some trouble giving up the lead and
now now hopefully he will
um still be in the driver's seat when it
comes to the tournament
kind of gets stuck here
and if you go to Rook G6 I got G3 and
the spawn might fall so even this
doesn't look very simple so arrival Bar
says equal but I think practically this
can be a bit unpleasant so if we take
take
here F4 this reformal is kind of nasty
yeah maybe I don't like
age five needs to be played
and then even if we lose this Pawn maybe
we maybe actually we don't lose this
phone so immediately this rule cannot
move so if you go with this Rook
what what do we want to do this is such
a funny looking piece here why not
okay I always want to go to these pawned
out end games why not F6
I have six like F6 and if you take on F6
and I take and you take on uh C6
like H4 or something
I don't know how far you want to push
this one because maybe not H4 maybe like
teenage seven yeah they found this power
maybe instead of H5 then you can just go
not that I'm not attacking you can't go
here
you don't have to commit to H5
yeah if you're gonna play F6 I don't
think H5 is necessary I want H5 not to
lose my Rook because I just cannot move
my jade Rook G4 is trapping it yeah if
you go over xc3 I guess even Brooke f8
in this 2v this 2V1 would be impossible
to lose I think like if you took on C6
and I took on F4 I don't think I would
lose that in game no this one is the
easiest tour so on this one is actually
very hard to lose even if your king
stays here it's very hard I'll just play
Rook f8 to keep my Rook on the back rink
even you know
the worst possible not not really but
no this one
so where are we in the game so in the
game Queen 25
oh he didn't take in the game oh he did
yeah he played Queen oh this is a nice
move because of here we win this back
and then F yeah
this theme that F6 is just his whenever
he wants it is uh coming back
patience Queen cannot move there is mate
um so take is not possible so maybe
Rook D1
but now we can take
yeah this is a much better version so we
didn't need to take on F6 Queen D5 is a
very classy move I like it
forcing the screen trade forcing the
queen trade on D5 maybe white can try
yeah but if you have to play a move like
F3 I think we're quite happy with black
and now Roku 36.
I like this because it also took away
this queen E5 square that we didn't like
F3 was played
and maybe Rook G5 is a possibility but I
don't think it's necessary but I think
this game is also entering the draw
territory I think black is handling
really well black survived the storm and
I think that's free yeah sir is in a
very comfortable spot right now
who's our other leader we have one more
leader right now yeah
so this one was a Spanish
it's 1986 Bishop B5
so Castle Bishop C5 our candles or
hangouts
d3b5
so this lines are very sharp and very
complicated with a million borders
what can uh play with seeds early A4 and
it takes I think they don't have to take
immediately
so now it goes to C3
Bishop G4
and black take so usually black doesn't
give up this bishop so easily but here
he does it for a very concrete reason
because after take there is Knight D4
and white cannot preserve the bishop if
the queen moves back this is actually
this Pawn structure is not something
white wants
so white gives out the bishop so now we
have opposite color Bishop position and
the Bishops are very similar because
this one is aiming and F7 this one is
aiming at f2 so very similar structure
C6 and this Pawn structure is also quite
similar if this B2 pound went to B4 is
be symmetrical
so the Knight goes to E3 headed to F5
possibly so G6 opposite G3
27 King G2 Knight D7 and
through goes to A8 so I think it's also
possible at some point to play for F5
okay so now we have a symmetrical Pawn
structure
actually
[Music]
um
close here too
so H5 is played
Bishop goes back uh yeah instead of H5 I
was thinking about the move Queen E6 is
that something silly because I just
wanted to stop Bishop B3 for the time
being
um
again not not sure I have the greatest
intuition for these sorts of positions
no I think this makes sense uh because
so why when Bishop C2 temporarily to
play B4 and then put the bishop back on
B3
um
so maybe I need to prepare it anyways
like here I'm done
yeah maybe here like kinji oh sure yeah
um I didn't want to give away the a file
but yeah
what uh
yeah maybe but
she's 17. then if you take ah if you
take I take and they win material okay
so this didn't work out and I mean I was
just thinking originally to play Queen
of six
and
how can I be worse
I I think the position is quite level
I think
maybe black is trying to go for some
kind of a pawn break
at some point with F5 so H5
like with the idea of putting the pawn
on H4 and asking quite how they're going
to react so what did white play as a
bishop so let's say if I go H4
and if you play something like G4 this
is actually annoying because I go now I
put everything on the dark squares and
then I go Knight F6 Knight H7 Knight G5
and my knight is very annoying here and
possibly E6 and F4 so I can just
maneuver my knight and
uh bring it to if the Knight gets to F4
then that would be pretty bad for white
so H4
maybe allows Queen G4 this is hanging
maybe I can actually take and defend
this Pawn at some point in a funny way
but H5 can be an annoying move for uh
why to do it after Queen G4 I think
black might be just tactically in a
whole lot of trouble like defending G6
is not easy like King G7 fails tonight
F5
so you have to play a move like Kane H7
and then you can even take and consider
playing H5
I I don't like black here so much no we
got too ambitious with H4 but uh the
thing about this kind of moves just
because you're an H5 and you have H4 as
an idea it doesn't mean you have to play
it immediately you can just play it at
some point it's just in the air
so he goes King G7 getting the king out
of the pin Queen goes back Knight F6
and now H4 and up and the question is
it's not that H4 is winning the game or
doing something devastating it's just
asking why how are you going to react to
this move
so white decides to exchange and go
Knight G2
and now black is forced to take because
this Pawn is hanging
and now we have this Rook iron and F7
but this this is very useful because of
the queen link were to go away like if
white were to play like I don't know
this is not a good series of moves but
like Rook B8 Queen C2 or whatever
then uh oh actually no I miscalculated
I'm just hallucinated I thought that you
could go like Knight G4 takes Rook h8
Knight H4 then Rook H4 takes Queen H4
but you just go kg2 but then you take on
what you two wait what are we trying I'm
trying to make but I think we're forcing
a draw or not even
yeah after Rook H4 you just take and
uh wait so this is a draw this is a
professional but I think if I go here
now I have a double thread and after I
take here you're not gonna take it with
a check so yeah you've been playing
badly for white I didn't make this idea
work
but maybe
I do like the bishop on B6 though like
cutting off the king yeah at some point
this could be useful
so it goes Rook T8 which is not the most
accurate move so Knight H4 and now D5
the Knight goes back so then I actually
really like this maneuver because the
Knight on G2 didn't look very impressive
so Exchange
Queen D6
and let's see let's reach the final
position sorry the one Queen E7 okay so
what is going on in this position so
there's quite a few
things going on here right
so the E5 Pawn is weak E4 Pawn is much
weaker because it's isolated so this
bishop is eyeing this F7 square if you
take d8 you have to take with the bishop
right because if you play Queen takes
then E5 is just I think they're
repeating I
so let's see so it's
Taurus move and let's see if he's going
to repeat but yeah that was actually a
good question I was also wondering if
Rook d8 how do you take back
you have to yeah you're right because if
I take break this way this just hangs
although I'm not sure how clean of a
pond this is let's say I go Queen where
do I go so I was thinking if you go like
Queen E7 I was just gonna take it
I thought you take this with a temple
this Exchange
are you saving this phone
see for
can I take this oh I mean this is all
just forcing moves but I wanted to go
here and then if you take
and then maybe I can
but that you have an idea no I don't
have no 95 sorry 98.
but it's probably the same sort of thing
like Bishop C7 here even okay it does
feel like taking three Bishop E1 getting
traded here
yeah should be a draw
but where are we so Queen is seven
so how many times did we repeat so Rook
D1 Queen E7 so I think Rook F1 is
so Rook D1 Queen E7 Rook F1 26 root 31
Queen sensor Rook F1 is already
no it's not third uh so we have a result
in the game between Daniel darha and um
uh Yasir quesada Perez and it appears
that they have drawn their game the
kings are in the center of the board
so in the position where we left off not
quite here so after F3 you want C5 a
really nice move getting rid of this
problematic C6 pawn and again is in no
rush to take on F6 because this Pawn is
his
so after d takes Queen takes they just
exchange everything
and there is no draw before move 40 so
the original 40 and agree to a draw a
very reasonable result for this game
just as this result came in another
result came in in the B group Akshay
Challenger one of the leaders has also
drawn his game against Kirk uh gazarian
so not a super
um
a combative Day from the leaders but uh
they are still I think a lot of them had
the black pieces so they were just
trying to make a draw with black and
they'll focus on winning their games
with white
yeah so the final position uh looks very
even opposite color Bishops no way for
this bishop to get in and this is a
funny Constructor because the black king
cannot leave this bishop would come in
and the white king cannot believe this
bishop will come in so they're just
stuck shuffling back and forth with the
Bishops
so this seems like a very level uh
game actually let's check out this game
versus contouring with holevsky and wow
wait what happened to my central defense
this used to be a white part yeah it
changed colors somehow but you know they
were in time travel so uh this is it
still looks good for white you know with
the outside pawns so let's see so we
left off here we'll get our eval bar so
Bishop B2 we're somewhere around here we
left off Bishop
for necessary
Queen F2
and doubling okay so black fan some
counter play deep Hive so The Rook on D2
is quite useful because also defense B2
after the Queens come off
so Bishop takes
and
so schwirtz and block have drawn their
game which means I believe every leader
in the a group has drawn so there will
be
um nobody running away with the
tournament as of yet yeah so some people
some players can still catch up with
them with wins but two out of three so
far is leading in group a
so in this position what was played King
E3 but D6 is also a reasonable right or
maybe he thought there is no way to
break their altar eventually before B5
will come I think yeah I like D6 can get
three but also reasonable centralizing
the king okay they're repeating wait why
did why did he not play King D4 there
was some concrete reason
so if you take I play CD
and I want to play King C5 next does
this not look like really good for white
okay
if you place a king on B6 this will be
quite problematic
um I think maybe he was trying to repeat
the position and game sign game time but
then he went Rook D3
I mean it's quite a long time so I think
maybe he's afraid of any kind of
commitments
okay B5 and I think this is how we ended
up with that structure yeah
Rook Sivan very reasonable move Rook C5
Bishop C6 and PS4 and this is where we
are In fairness this still looks really
good for white
pawns on B4 and B5 make make some kind
of impression yeah if this pawns uh this
Rook
don't think this Rook can move because
the spawn will run so what is the idea I
think the idea is to bring the king here
and this other rook in yeah it's
important to point out I think that um
actually yeah if you move your Rook to
any square if the pawn gets to B7 like I
think you can just resign with black
because I'll move my Bishop away and go
Rook C8 and
um
you just have no more moves
this Pawn has to be stopped here so The
Rook on V8 is paralyzed but also moving
this Rook is dangerous because this one
starts to move which is why I wanted to
bring my king so white has a really nice
domination
because this bishop is also stopping The
Rook from going to E8 so there is
nothing no moves like rookie six King
goes here and maybe something like
rookie eights looking for some activity
because we'll just take
so there's a nice domination The Rook
moves 94 is hanging so now I think
actually we're getting quite close to
White
um
slowly actually not so slowly just
converting because once this rule comes
in and if cancer wins this game he will
have uh clear first in the tournament we
will have two
so far pretty smooth game today he
maybe he had some tactical ways of
playing in the opening but he decided to
just grab a pawn and now he has a huge
Advantage with this extra point he went
King Yvonne
which I don't think makes a difference
because the pawn can also be stopped
from D2 or maybe his next one will be
king D2 and just looks pretty
straightforward winning for wide yeah
this is this is the kind of thing that I
do all the time like I'm just I just
assume I'm gonna blunder a tactic in
every position so if I play keaney too
like my opponent will play Bishop C4 one
day and they'll win somehow so he goes
Kini one because just to avoid even an
idea of Bishop C4 probably it's the same
as when your opponent has a knight you
don't put your pieces on the same color
so they don't get four you can put one
on black Square another one in the parts
for another light Square so they can
never be a fork so we expect this game
to be a win for white and we have some
other games so actually have a lot of
games we haven't looked at
let's take a look we have this game
between Felix and Luca so we have this
final position where there's a Pawn on
E7 so we have one two three four five
six against five so white is up a pawn
but opposite color Bishops this Pawn is
blockaded so the Rooks give white
um an extra
chances to win this but the opposite
color but that was the color Bishops is
always very very tricky I think the end
game I I you can correct me if I'm wrong
but I think the end game is winning if
we can trade Rooks and take the C Pawn I
don't think black can hold because at
some point I'll go B3 and there's this
like one diagonal rule where you need to
be able to hold White's past pawns on
one diagonal or you'll lose and I will
push my a pawn eventually and I don't
think black can hold if he loses a c
Pawn
so if I go here and then I go here I
think eventually it'll just be zugged
out
um
like uh oh you're gonna so if I do
something like this you're gonna go here
yeah like I'll play like Bishop D4 and
then B4 and then when you take I'll play
if it should be two or something
okay so the point is
so I cannot go here
because queens and if I go here
you go here and then you put your Bishop
here yeah and then this Pawn will run
also you can probably come and start
taking this Pawn I think in these end
games it's not so important whether or
not you give your opponent past pawns as
long as they'll get as long as you can
stop them obviously it's more important
that you can generate your own past
pawns because you need to create winning
chances somehow and the pawn on E7 is
not enough to win
so in the game this was played the
requirement here and Bishop B8
so he's keeping an active Rook so Bishop
E8 had to be played Rook f8 was a huge
threat
so and the point is if you go here
now we get very active
and I think this eyeing on this B2 point
is very important so if you take okay
this trade we're thrilled about this
Vlog I don't think you can lose the end
game after you take the B2 Pawn it's
pretty difficult
but manageable I well I mean I'd lose
but yeah so the point is now
of this A4 um
so the bishop can do two things at the
same time both stop the pawn and defend
this A4 Pawn
stop this E7 pawn and defend it so if we
take this Rook off the board this is a
very easy drive because black will just
Shuffle with the with the the bishop
back and forth so it'll be very easy to
run
but of course white will not allow this
white is not going to allow E2 but the
rookie rookie 4 is also an idea and from
E4 I'm actually also holding this Pawn
but let's say I make a move
which I need to find this white let's
say I go here you go here and I go oh I
don't have this because immediately you
take
so I go rookie four but I'm not really
threatening anything but from here at
least I'm defending C4
but but I also don't have moves so this
is kind of tricky so let's say I go here
so you just Shuffle right so you just
don't have any other move yeah maybe
bishop beef like as a or no sorry I I
want to win his weight I don't want to
play Black's position sorry like her key
six I'll play like Bishop B4 and then
Rook C8 and then try to play King C3
um
so it's hard to achieve something
without giving fun of this fun so I
don't know maybe you can give up this G2
opponent but with the Rooks on the board
if you win C4 it doesn't seem as
impressive
because if you go before and I take my
Pawn is actually moving so I think uh
this maybe this was a fortress already
yeah it's
it's unfortunate because it seems like
so close to yeah
and it's kind of funny right every
single Pawn is on a light Square yeah in
every single Pawn for white sun on a
dark Square
so
except the g21 I'm doing something wrong
okay so Bishop E8 I need to
so promote variation so we are where the
game is yeah so black has just enough
squares to actually make moves and
rookie 6 rookie 4 these are the moves
that black is going to make if the Rook
moves from
T8 now we can go Bishop B5 perhaps
but I'm also curious about this end game
if I go here and you take can I hold
this
foreign
what what am I trying to do here
if I go E3
takes takes but here I'm losing another
phone right
or no I don't no like if
instead of taking E3 like
can we take C4 no but here I think I'm
quite happy because yeah you just go you
want to take E7 okay
I'm not so sure I want to do that yet
because I think I have one more move
right oh you take G2
first and then do that oh no King B5
okay I can't allow this okay
but maybe this is
and then
this should be yes I don't want to say
an easy draw but if my I run with my
king you also have the wrong Vision okay
but I will run with my king so you will
have to defend this
and then if I run with my king even if
you make this Pawn Yeah having the wrong
Bishop actually is very relevant here
because that means that
um well actually maybe it's not so
relevant because how do you win a piece
but
even if you do manage to win a piece on
the on the king side somehow I just have
the cane in the corner that's over
oh I know how because
yeah just to be instructive so for
example we go here this king is waiting
[Music]
so Christopher you has actually defeated
uh gladora in the a group oh we did not
do that which is exciting so Christopher
is black so let's see how we got here
quickly
so actually we will have Christopher and
we can ask him about the game yesterday
yeah his game yesterday was fantastic so
definitely interested in what he has to
say about that game
wow this is a lot of content
I just
I'm so Queen detail oh again he's no
he's not down a piece because he's
taking wow this game again he has like a
million puns
man every game that Christopher plays is
just super interesting oh wow yeah okay
before I take but this kid is good at
good at tactics
kids tend to be
team one rookie two but uh yeah this
Pawn has to be very difficult to deal
with G5 is really nice
I'm taking if I'm not mistaken this
means that Christopher is tied for first
now right
uh Christopher no he lost the game right
in the first round he lost to quesada
oh my mistake
so he's back on 50 so if he goes F3 this
is a Perpetual so he goes H6
and
oh no you is actually at two points he
like he is tied for first how is it he
drew yesterday and he won today he won
today but I think he drew against uh
quesada Perez though no no he lost
okay well
can come from later
is that um
it was that two pieces were so stroke
and then eventually it was Queen versus
rook and quesadawan and
from that one right
the other one who the other one who
played that fantastic game oh okay I was
thinking he could play Christopher okay
Chris forger his first game then yeah so
Christopher is at two points okay so
we'll ask him about this game and we
will ask him about
um yesterday's game so it'll be exciting
to talk to him
and since we are in group a so we do
have a so this game this game is over
right so true bulk
there is no way this game is still going
is this um I think this is already yeah
Doris schwertson Benjamin Bach have
already drawn okay I forgot Queen the
six uh so save Andrew
draw so we have three draws and one
decides the result and the other game is
Abu is playing against Notre back so
this game is going to be a draw there's
just no pieces left on
yeah this game has also been drawn so
group a is actually over so we had one
decisive result and four draws and in
group b
we have this game uh this game between
Victor mikowski that's still going so we
have one result here right we have aksha
to drill
and Felix versus Luca we're thinking
this will without we think this is a
fortress already and we have two games
we haven't looked at Jason Liang some
kind of a French structure where the
light Square Bishop is gone so very nice
French
so it comes from a sicilian this is the
only way to get rid of that Bishop
so Bishop G5 so we're going to see a lot
of Trades here and D6 is played Rook fc1
but I understand why it wants to play on
the queen side
so the Bishops are actually saved and
now this is how we get this French
structure
um this part is actually quite weak and
this French structures and white is
quite happy to exchange the dark Square
Bishops but
white black is very happy to exchange
the light squared Bishops it probably
exchanges in general favor Black in this
type of position due to having less
space
if uh if uh White is left with this Pawn
with everything that's off it can be
quite annoying
so G4 so trying to go
something like H5 G5 like long term as
you pointed out the pawn on D4 is weak
so white is trying to generate counter
play on the on the king side such that
he doesn't need to play some endgame
where he's left to defend the D4 upon
yeah this Advanced French positions are
very difficult to play strategically I
really like this King run because maybe
something is coming so he just runs away
with the King doesn't want to deal with
it
Queen on the light squares
so just shuffling back and forth for a
few moves
and I don't know if they're
such as shuffling is there going to be
okay but this is going to be it's funny
though
E8 D7 then went back he like ran all the
way there and then he ran all the way
back I like this move Knight A1 oh yeah
me too so black I think is ready to make
a drop but white is like no but okay if
we go for this
um
can we
no but I don't think white can get
adventurous because this Pawn actually
yeah but okay yeah Perpetual so I think
this is also in a draw territory
and oh this is another game we haven't
had a chance to look at
and this is club.in
so let's see I was looking at this game
before we started the broadcast so this
is
Prince Gambit the client The Exchange
variation with Bishop G5
and you're mentioning that H6 is not a
move that black really wants to play
yeah typically in this opening black
doesn't want to play H6 because later
you play the maneuver Knight D7 fag6 and
it usually white puts their Bishop on D3
and Queen on C2 and having the pawn on
H6
um means that G6 is a weaker square and
white might just be able to win upon on
that pawn in the future
so the Bishops lights back castles
Bishop goes to D3
Queen C2 so all of this very logical
and Bishop G3
because 94 is a move in this positions
so black is offering in exchange 95 if
you mentioned that this is a pleasant
trick yes
the bishop E5 is a very unusual decision
I think it's it's based off very
concrete play because if you just play
Bishop E5 and you give white the bishop
then you're much you have to be much
worse but black probably gets the bishop
back right away yeah because of
now at H5 is possible but also this
actually maybe hangs upon
because F4 is not a move I just take
here so that's why Bishop E5 is played
but now Knight D7 and this bishop just
gets kicked around so Bishop goes to F4
and here this move really surprised me
because white is left with this Pawn
structure so it also almost feels like
black is up a pawn because I have Force
versus three on the queen side and you
have double Pawns
so Knight goes back
to eyeing the spawns Knight only six but
the Knight gets kicked out
Queen F4 offer in the queen exchange
that this Knight is not this Knight is
not where it's meant to be
the Knight goes to F6 but the Knight
needs to be on D6 here
is headed there
it looks like white actually gets a lot
of play Oh F6 that's all
with the idea to ruin the pawn structure
and go after this Pawn
and can we not hang on to this Pawn
oh that's very nice that's a very nice
tactical shot so you probably missed
Knight D5 yeah so you can't play Knight
D5 right away because uh black will have
the move Kinney seven like take take any
seven
um so white first plays F6 takes and
then Rook H5 to lure the cane away from
the E7 square and then you have knighted
and Knight takes D5 that's this is so
nice it's a cool idea
King G7 Knight D5
and now we are no we're not up upon one
two three four five against five but the
pawns are a different quality the
quality of the fonts is important
so takes and this Pawn is actually going
to be marching down the board
and I can get four
which is six okay so clearing the path
of the pawn
and now D5
Rook D2 King E3 so if we take it should
be four oh Bishop A4 is very strong very
nice
so now the Rook has to go to D1 and now
maybe Rook D4 right because this end
game looks awful for black this cannot
be hold above we'll go D6 now the king
cannot move this is defended eventually
you can come take this Pawn
this um
the king can go in all throughout
actually the king will just go here
between the pawn we don't have to go
take other pawns yeah so this looks
winning for white so in group a we said
everything is done so we have
Christopher who won we will probably get
an interview with Christopher so and in
this we will have we're expecting
at this game this game I think is gonna
end in a repetition you go Knight C2
Knight A5
I don't think this is a good trade for
uh for white because you're just
activating this queen
so I think this game will be a drum this
game
oh what happened here so this game Bike
will play for a long time and kirkelly
let's see what happened has happened
here we're expecting a result in this
game so we saw all of this
so we stopped after King Yvonne so H6 is
played King goes to D2 G5
okay black is looking for some kind of
active play otherwise the spawns are
just queening
but also giving himself another Target
so he calls after this Pawn
but not that the king is far away I
would consider
doing this
and maybe Rook Asics that he checks and
rogifty with ship E6 perhaps G4 is
devastating here
unless I'm allowing but I don't think
this is anything significant because if
I take
yeah this also looks pretty winning but
maybe it was showing a lot of counter
play
maybe G4 is unnecessary maybe still for
gate three yeah like your Rook A3 and
then with the idea like Rook A6 maybe
then B6 B7 just Queen the pawn
although we have to be careful with that
because Bishop Bishop C8 might be a
trick that black has
okay so let me
[Music]
think Bishop C8 tactically doesn't work
out
yeah Bishop B7 Bishop B7 is
good enough
and then you have to win with this extra
no but here I think this is quite easy
because this Falls immediately
yeah and worst case scenario you blunder
into rook and Bishop versus Rook which
uh yeah
I've actually never had that end game I
I've had that end game or Winning Side I
had it with um the bishop and I won in
like 20 moves oh wow my
uh yeah I don't know how people hold
that in game in real life they just
snowed really well or their opponent
just cannot because I think sometimes
you're like winning and you have you
figure out like a sequence to win and
then you just don't find it yeah I know
Philadelphia's position which basically
happened in my game
and then I just converted
have you ever had to defend it I have
never had to defend yeah I had to do
checkmate with Knight on Bishop once but
I had a lot of times I figured out I was
nervous I thought if I don't do it it's
gonna be really embarrassing yeah
so we have a result in this there was
one case where somebody didn't mate with
Knight and Bishop and then
then uh people yeah people got scared
afterwards but yeah I think they're like
this is embarrassing I cannot imagine or
somebody like that no it was
um
uh I know who it was I cannot think of
her name I can I know but it was someone
really good but it's someone I played
before I I know exactly who it is I just
cannot think of her name I had to sing
last one time so I couldn't think of the
name
so we have one result so dumbass
remember Turin did win that game after
King E3 black decided that enough
suffering the game is um
game is over here
and so in this section we will have
interview with Christopher use soon but
we do have
a few more games going on in Group B so
this game against Gregory Hunter and we
currently michalevsky we're expecting
white to win to convert this and the
other game that might have a result is
the game between Felix and Luca where
with that that black would be playing
rookie 8 to Rook E4 but instead
instead he decided to put his Rook on C6
so we're thinking that this is good
enough to draw but the Rook went to C6
now Bishop D6 and now I have to think if
how can
write make progress because when The
Rook was on the e-file we had a very
difficult time moving our King to C3
because there was this rookie 3 check
but now it's actually possible
but the bishop goes back and the spawn
is actually starting to hang
but we do have the winner of the round
from group a Christopher you
congratulations on your win so you've
been playing some really exciting chess
and we wanted to look at both of your
games from yesterday and today so let's
start with today's game let's take us
through a key moment of this game
um
so first of all Queen B6 is a strange
looking move but um it's to prevent D4
and it was kind of some preparation for
this game and after Queen B6 he seemed
to be already out of Series so he was
spending a lot of time from move five or
so
so you want b3s and natural move D5
Google Bishop B2 takes takes Bishop B2
Bishop E7 and it looks like he was just
playing safe save chess I think that's
generally his style to play relatively
positionally and
um
let's try to slowly out for you Knight
E5 is very much in his style and I take
C6 Queen takes C6 Knight C3 B5 yeah I'm
excited to get like this
Pawn while A5 B5 c5d5 and you manage so
you had a really nice Pawn ball here so
when did you start thinking that your
your position is or you're doing well
already
I still felt like it was just a normal
position I didn't feel like I was doing
well or badly okay
so Rook T8 so you're just putting
everything
yeah here I started to get complicated
when I proceed for
Queen B1 94.
I think he should have just played like
Bishop D4
or something Queen B2B take C4
um like Bishop takes E4 B takes C4 and
sorry what do you say after Bishop D4
what
Queen D6 okay
yeah and it starts getting quite
problematic um because you cannot take
back so you have to stick here
Queen takes B5
so what was your plan then after Bishop
D4
um I was considering Bishop C5 maybe
yeah
[Music]
she takes
C5 Maybe
take C5 Bishop takes E4 D takes E4
CJC for B4
and then yeah and just play this
position
how would you evaluate this position
um maybe some compensation for black
okay so instead instead he went D3 yeah
I mean maybe D3 is fine and I went
Knight D2 and starts getting very
complicated it's a funny variation with
Bishop D4 I think he should have played
Bishop D4 because they have to play
Queen takes D4
he takes D4 and Knight takes B1
good case E7 C takes B3 vert takes B1
V takes A2 we're getting one and Bishop
C6
group takes A2 A4
and apparently there's actual
compensation for the piece because it's
hard for him to deal with p4b3 all right
because this piece is started oh this
bishop is just yeah kind of silly here
so this is how you play every game you
just give up a piece for past funds
um did I also sacrifice the piece
yesterday against Avi
and
uh yeah yeah yesterday you're I guess
it's a reoccurring scene in this
tournament so far so that's the key for
your opponents to make sure yeah you
don't get a lot of fun so just trade
fonts in the beginning and then
everything is good
so queen of two Bishop takes E1 Queen
takes E1 V takes A2 Rook A1
B4 and yeah this was kind of part of my
calculation so vertex A2 V3 and I was
really hoping that he played Bishop D4
so I'm able to sacrifice my queen and he
was actually generous and
um so what else can he do here but it's
difficult because because I always have
Rook C2 but I think Queen takes A5 is
what I saw was the best one before
because Queen takes A5 or takes A5 Rook
C2 Bishop D4
V2 revision takes P2 takes B2 Bishop
takes D5 I thought this should be draw
yeah
so you think he was being ambitious with
Bishop D4 I wonder if he overlooked
Queen takes D4 yeah that's an easy move
to overlook yeah so you take and here
yeah he thought he could defend my Pawn
because it's not that let's say queen A1
Rook C2 Bishop F3
rookie eight because Bishop D1 Ricky won
two gun the problem the promised is T3
Pawn because just stopping tonight and
blocking those Bishop it's actually
quite annoying so he went King F1
Bishop C6
Bishop D1 verb D2
this should be free and now that's such
a nice completely dominating this night
and I think he's lost at this point
Queen C3
oh yeah Bishop takes A2 I think he won
Bishop takes A2 yeah take the pawn queen
C3 and now just one more nice move Rick
ee2
other otherwise um let's say Rook takes
A2 Queen takes C6
he's probably holding because Rook E2
Queen C8 and then something G4 Perpetual
yeah this is very annoying
but if Rook E2 first
and I have now I have vertex F2 check
intermediate mover takes eight and then
I I checked the engine briefly and
apparently Rick takes A2 almost messed
up the wind because he had Queen F6
which apparently holds the game oh with
a perpetual
I I think I have to go like Rook G2 Rook
takes H2 wait no not Rick takes H2 I'm
not perpetual
engine was still saying like minus one
somehow so there was a
um
it looks like Perpetual to me so yeah
yeah right so
gf2 no but I'm very happy they have two
rookie too oh then rookie two yeah okay
Rick Rick takes Rick GF wait Rick takes
H2 or takes H2 but how is
yeah wait how is this not Perpetual oh I
think
I think it looks really great
but
yeah it remains difficult yeah if I
check and take is this
it's probably winning in the long term
right yeah
but I mean this white is so happy to get
this right compared to what happened in
the game
so rookie two so instead of taking on A2
what should you do
um
can you go F3 I think throw in a check
first let's say your cakes F2 King G1 it
says like for G2 check
and then and then work
here
[Music]
so here again so we stop the check
so King has to go to F1 yeah
and
where's the word wait now we cover gf2
where it takes A2 wait this is the same
thing
this is very difficult to figure out
yeah
so what's
Queen CA Queen G4 yeah okay that's the
perpetual
okay we can check
so Rook do two
oh so you go here here here in Rook C2
oh because okay this is very same team
as you had in the game so you're
threatening mate
but anyways he wasn't able to find a
defense after Rook takes A2 we'll sit
down on time yeah I only had one minute
he won Queen takes D5 and H6 was nice
and he simply has no checks yeah because
as we showed us that if you try
F3 unfortunate Perpetual in the dark
Square so H6 and yeah this is just
indefensible he takes Rook C2 and
one of them will deliver meat very nice
game
thanks and uh so I have to
just give me a second so I can find how
to find my game yesterday yes but no I
went to the wrong one
so and then
I saw that Anish giri commented that it
was from his chorus
but I don't know if it's the new course
or is the course that's been published
or hasn't been published and he's doing
a new course
so tell us about this game yeah this was
a crazy game so how much of it was your
prep up to move 20 or so I had this
bishop G2 Bishop takes F6 so is this all
your analysis or this is his course oh
um this was on my analysis so before G5
did he was he also playing so he was
also playing quickly did you talk to him
after the game yeah so we analyzed the
variations there's a lot of interesting
moments so was he also in his proper I'm
assuming you have to be in here yeah
okay so you played rookie one so just
tell me when you're out of book
um move 22 so 95 we should see it uh so
Rook F1 F1 so this is the last movie you
know and he went directly for so what
were you expecting here B6 and what's
the point Knight C4 Bishop B7 yeah
and how would how do we evaluate this
um like zeros yeah
but it's easier to play for white
because you have two extra Knights
um
so what's the plan for white how do you
you can go like in b2a3 and just play
the position
and that's just kind of maybe Queen H7
at some point start collecting
on a very good day so instead he won
Rook D4 so this is the first thing you
take in the game okay so I see you spend
like 18 minutes
um so did you so when he plays Rook D4
and it's not your prep so you thought
this is already a mistake
he I wasn't sure yeah but I know you
what I knew it wasn't the best move
but it was it was difficult to figure
out over the board but I think I made a
good decision to play Knight E4
because Rick takes before Queen H5
and my friend Rick takes F7
so instead he went P6
and ah you're actually on the other side
of your opponent having a lot of fun so
even C3 and things got really crazy here
did you consider anything else here
Queen H7 yeah
it's a grenade seven he has to play I
think King f8 is his only move because
what happened you just Queen G7
Knight F6 Queen G5
yeah 95 this looks quite bad so okay so
he will play here
Knight takes G5 yeah workout four
okay what happens if I take it takes out
seven yeah and I takes up seven in case
of seven b takes C5
and your claim is this king is too weak
the special event you have a strong Pawn
Yeah Yeah that's a that's a strong claim
okay so here I have to play drug F4
okay and I didn't really like this that
much during the game but apparently it's
better after Knight C4
this is a good imbalance
so yeah his boy cannot untangle yeah
okay so let's go to the game because the
game was quite exciting so this happened
Queen E7 this position looks very iffy
because of his King situation
but it's not as it's not so easy to
Checkmate but
it really felt like I should have a
better position during the game here and
you also had a
tower on him here no not enough 40
minutes on him so Rook C1 which is a
mistake so what did you think your plan
is to try to quit this fun or go after
his king or like what I was just trying
to go after the king or just yeah right
should be 7 95 Queen itself and yeah
here Knight D3 was a really strong move
and he has nothing to do about 95.
oh because even here this is just this
is just Queen G6 did you consider the
third game
it's it's hard to say I was considering
94.
for some reason I I saw 94 and then I
didn't see Knight D3 because it takes
work F1
immediately
the problem with Knight E4 this is such
a funny pumpkin yeah
okay is King E7 and then Knight takes G5
Queen f8 wow
it's kind of ridiculous but yeah
hurricane F6
and if I continue oh yeah
age six yeah
so here you already have to start going
back and you didn't
is this so bad
I go Queen G3
I doubt it's I feel like black has
counted by though Queen F6
um so many points yeah I wanted to play
Queen A3 like if you want that for my
ideas B5 Queen A3 is is a is actually a
plan so so it's it's yeah yeah but okay
four is a very ugly move to play yeah
okay so where are we kind of got lost in
let's go back to the game yeah so queen
of seven and then you decided yeah but
unfortunately my Pawn cannot green
easily because he has this move E4
walking my Bishop with
Queen H3
Queen F6
yeah here I could have won Queen A3
Queen A3 B5 yeah this is variations are
crazy like E4
B5
D3 king beef
King B1
King F7
Knight takes D7 Queen D4
this is what I saw at the engine after a
game oh okay I was gonna test zero
it runs to safety King G6 King H6
the position is just
crazy it's kind of funny because now
your queen feels like out of the game
sort of because the spawns are running
and the King goes to safety and your
queen would be in red review on H5 maybe
now
okay so 97
so all of this happened the Knight takes
D7 was bad I simply missed so okay let's
go Knight takes C7 King takes D7 Queen
D3 E4 it takes D3 King B3 I kind of
hallucinated rook d8 and I realized that
I really messed things up and this Pawn
on D3 is really strong
but the game goes on but um so did you
think you're in another adventure here
already yeah oh you think you're already
in danger because the spawns are coming
so you miss Rook d8 or you thought you
have something when I play Knight takes
D7 okay
so he found a very nice resource if five
and now he's just pushing his pawns and
then you still had some winning chances
in the end I believe
right it's around here yeah
so all of this happened so there's one
Queen
yeah this was very funny yeah
and is that he took and he we found
Queenie free after the game but he
didn't see it during the game Queen D3
King G5 and now it's tough to defend
iPod I just Pawn on B4 that's pretty
strong
he has a lot of checks that he has to
deal with his King is shaky and like
kind of in danger but Bishop D3 was not
good if I went B5 yeah this is very
tough for him because his King is very
bad on F5 because he cannot push the
spawn right he's I think F3 somehow yeah
with something like
yeah a bunch of checks and Queenie for
Queen F3
so but uh so in this kind of position
like how do you approach this because
you have an hour on your clock so spend
a lot of time
like how do you make a decision here
I really I really should have spent a
lot of time in this position well I mean
now it's easy to say right because you
haven't made a mistake during the game I
just got tempted to to take the pawn
with Chuck with Bishop D3 but
um if I had spent maybe like 10 minutes
I could have figured out that P5 was
better
but yeah it is pretty difficult so this
is this is really this kind of
complicated position I think you should
spend
a lot of time but um I I don't know I
felt like it had kind of gotten out of
hand at this point so
maybe psychologically I should have just
reset and still tried to take my time
and make good moves yeah yeah I think
this is like the most difficult thing in
chess when there is a big shift in the
position to kind of bring yourself back
psychologically and not just um kind of
Lose Yourself and get um too emotional
so okay so here um
so you played Bishop D3 and you took the
pawn so do you did you feel like you're
in danger here and you already have to
try to force a draw or you're like happy
with the drawer I didn't feel like I was
in danger but um I didn't feel like it
was winning anymore let's say yeah so
when did you feel like the game
completely you lost complete control of
the game at which one when I went um
Knight takes D7 oh yeah I wanted to say
don't say 97
so from then on you just thought things
got completely out of hand
so it can get four P5 so
yeah and then we said I saw this part
yesterday
yeah then there were a lot of there's a
lot of
crazy
moves but also and it all it ended up in
a drawn position yeah and then you just
agreed here
so how did you feel about this game
overall
very very
crazy and shaky from both sides but it
was it was um interesting it was a fight
yeah it was it was a good fight how did
he feel about the game was he happy with
the results I think he was happier than
me because his position was very shaky
while I was mostly pressing
so he seemed pretty happy to defend the
position
yeah it was it was a fun game
despite all the mistakes
um there were a lot of interesting
moments yeah this was a really
fascinating game we really enjoyed it
and your game today was also very
interesting so really appreciate you
playing this kind of chance and
we look forward to you playing more
exciting games and hopefully we see you
again after more wins so thank you for
joining us thank you
so let's continue with our games so
we're done with group a so let's move on
to Group B we are in this game between
gergelic Hunter and Victor mikhalevsky
so we are past move 40.
so where we left off was around here
Rook G3 check was played Rook went to F3
Bishop E6 and white played we'll get our
eval bar bike King D3 King G5
so repeating uh King G5 and now Rook H1
so let's try to understand the idea
behind this I think White's idea is
still going to be a rook A1 to A6 or A7
I do like the king bedroom on D3 because
in some lines we were seeing moves like
Rook h8 Rook H2 check but it's no longer
possible
so we do I do like the whatever white
did bringing the king to D3 and I think
eventually The Rook Will Go On
i1 and uh convert this position
and let's see how many games we have
left so we have oh this game is going so
the the players are still trying I
thought this game would end in
repetition but I do expect this to and
then a draw I don't think there's a way
to make progress and Felix versus Luca
there's opposite color Bishop position
that we have going so we actually only
have two games going uh three games
going kirkelly Hunter versus michalesky
we expect gergeli to win and we expect
the other two games and in a draw
yeah yeah so not a lot of decisive
results today certainly not as many as
yesterday but everybody is playing
pretty exciting and it seems like we're
going to have a clear winner in group b
and there's just a real fight at the top
in group a
um no one is playing as exciting as
Christopher yeah that is true
Christopher you certainly is the most
exciting player of the tournament right
now
yeah let's go ahead and take a look at
the standings what's happening so Sam
Seville and Dario Schwartz Christopher
you and Yasser quesada Perez are all
tied for first with two points out of
three a very hotly contested uh group
and uh the people leading uh the B group
right now are currently well Akshay
Chandra has two points out of three
games but we don't expect this to remain
the case we think that Cantor is
probably going to see a defeat Victor
michelevsky and
acquire Soul lead over the rest of the
field
with two and a half points out of three
and we do expect
some at least one decisive result in
this group and possibly two so it's been
a very interesting round again really
enjoyed my interview with Christopher
Yoon getting his insight about today's
games and yesterday's game and thank you
everyone for joining us and make sure
you're tuning in tomorrow at the same
time for round four of the spring
classic
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited